let's say that we want to figure out
what is 7 and 11 12
minus 1
and 6 12. pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
all right now let's work on this
together so there's a couple of ways
that you could approach this
you can view this as the same thing as 7
plus 11 12
and then minus
1
and you might be attempting to say minus
1 and then plus 6 12. but remember
you're subtracting not just the 1 you're
subtracting 1 and you're subtracting 6
12. so minus 1
minus 6 12.
now why is that useful to think about it
that way
well now you can think about the whole
number
so you could say this is going to be 7
minus 1
plus
11 12
plus 11 12
minus 6 12
minus 6 12
and so 7 minus one is six
so it's going to be six plus now if i
have 11 of something in this case
twelfths and i'm subtracting six of them
away six of the twelfths i'm going to be
left with five of those somethings five
twelfths so it's going to be 6 plus 5 12
which is the same thing as 6
and
5 12. now as you get more used to this
you could do some of this maybe even in
your head you could say hey look look at
the whole number parts
7
minus 1 is going to give me 6 and then
if i say 11 12 minus 6 12 is going to
give me 5 12. so that takes up a little
bit less base another way that you might
see this approached is you could rewrite
this as 7
and
11 12
minus
minus
1 and 6 12.
let me do the 6 12 in that blue color
that i'm
using for the fraction parts 6 12
and then i would first focus on the
fractional parts and i say 11 12 minus 6
12
is 5 12
and 7 minus 1
is 6 and i got 6 and 5 12. so many
different ways to approach the same
thing and at the at the end of the day
there really are the same underlying
idea